this town doing so well receipt your
solo your solo music out there I mean
how how is that for you being out there
on your own without your boys with your
brother's around you it's different
because there's no no one else around
but I've been enjoying it so fired the
performances that I've done and you know
it's just wish to spend funds this is
obviously a show that we've we've had
success out in previous years and had
some good performances and had some
great nights at and I'm looking forward
to it can let a few more memories you
may not have your brother's around your
1d around you but you got those fans
supporting I mean you feel that is that
kind of like help you kind of feel more
comfortable 100 oversight if you didn't
have the if you didn't have the funds in
there be a lost soul you know I haven't
you know it's it's great obviously you
guys some of you guys have been going
out solar with your music Liam's coming
out with some good music
how are your Styles different from each
other for me the stuff that I wanted to
make was was kind of you know you could
see you some of it into One Direction
stuff you know we can add a more
acoustic side of it you know and I think
you can see that with this town and more
songs on the record just naturally what
I would pick up and play on the guitar
and I've got a kind of an old soul when
it comes to music you know Liam bit more
it likes his beats a little bit more
yeah and Harry you know that Rob is that
more of a rocky edge what is rocky or
torn so I you know I yeah I guess it's
going to differ that way but your boy
Zane's obviously nominated tonight any
chance you've seen him tonight yeah
probably I haven't I'm you know spoke
haven't spoke to him in a few months or
whatever and I've seen him in a way so
I'm looking forward to seeing him
you